[Music]
we're here to talk today about a
partnership that we have with Google
called Accenture managed services for
GCP joined here with my colleagues frost
cantos and Matthew Abernathy we'll kind
of go through the solution how it fits
in the marketplace what's been the
client demand that we're seeing for this
with cloud providers and especially with
Google and GCP and why both ourselves
and Google very excited about this
partnership and and the kind of new
ideas and things that we can offer to
the enterprise that wasn't necessary
available as an option before for them
so let's move right into a map Thanks
we've been working quite for quite some
time with enterprise customers on their
on their journey to cloud and I wanted
to talk about how this kind of fits into
that because a lot of the enterprise
customers you know over the last four to
five years they've been spending a lot
of time on the on the on the left-hand
side of this chart actually working up
their strategy their assessment the
roadmap and coming up with a business
case and many times in that business
case it includes what are we going to
migrate whenever gonna migrate what are
the priorities what are we moving to are
we moving these applications to
infrastructure as a service platform as
a service software as a service when
when as part of the business case which
is always a big block in the business
case it could we potentially get out of
some of our data centers and get rid of
some of those assets wouldn't it be nice
if we can move everything we're doing to
more of a an OP X flexible model where
we can be off of what we're doing from a
capex perspective and those are usually
big-ticket items in the business case
and on the right hand side of the slide
here really now that we're actually
thinking about moving to cloud and doing
things in the cloud what could we do and
leverage in the industry around managing
operations so a lot of things that
Accenture has done with clients is on
the slide these are the services that
that we provide to clients and as part
of that
Accenture we've been on a journey as a
company ourselves to
leverage cloud technologies for our own
IT uses within our own corporation right
we're 450,000 person global company as
you can imagine quite a bit of IT to run
our own business right and so we've been
on a journey the last 7 years of moving
the majority of everything Accenture
does from an IT perspective to the cloud
and I believe we're over 95% in the
cloud today as a company and that and by
the way that was written in our strategy
and our business case over seven years
ago right and all of the tools and
things that we've built around strategy
business case work for our own company
and migration tools and migration
Factory we took all those and have
turned those into things that we bring
to customers as part of services and
what we're here to talk about today is
the one down in the far right there
we actually had built through time what
we call Accenture's application
optimized private cloud I know it's a
mouthful but it's Accenture is private
cloud and we offer and sell that to
customers so they could actually run
private cloud infrastructure run and
managed by Accenture and we can take on
their enterprise workloads and so what
we did with Google is in our partnership
was based our solution with Google on
this technology from Accenture that
we'll go into today let's move to the
next slide so today we've taken our
private cloud technology it is available
in u.s. East with Google and the same do
datacenter GCP is we have plans to
expand and offer the same private cloud
capability adjacent to Google cloud
platform in London and Frankfurt and
other locations as we go through time
the idea is many of the reasons that the
enterprise customers can't get out of
those data centers is they have a lot of
large application than workloads would
which will take them a significant
amount of time to refactor onto cloud
technologies things like Oracle
application Oracle Suites large sa P
landscapes with you know monster Hana
database
those are really big kind of items that
number one harder and longer to refactor
the cloud not necessarily it can do it
and and number two for maybe performance
or regulatory or compliance reasons it's
easier for them to leave it in the data
center for a while so this option allows
them to take those oracle workloads and
have them sitting in the data center
less than one millisecond away from GC
from GCP and in a private cloud that
will run that for them and we can run
oracle workloads and manage that for the
clients we can run s AP landscapes and
manage that for the clients up to the
largest in the world on this platform
and we can run bare metal for the
clients as well so if they have a
particular application you know i we're
starting to run into things that are 20
to 30 years old the enterprise still has
where they're just want a bare metal
server and they're gonna run it on this
platform but they want it next to the
cloud provider because they're moving
the majority of their applications to
the cloud cloud provider next slide so I
don't know if you've heard this term we
we've been using this the Accenture
quite a bit you know we talked about
hybrid cloud which this certainly is but
this is taking the hybrid cloud or
private cloud model to the next level
and it's cloudy Jason C meaning we're
taking the private cloud technology
sticking it less than one millisecond
away from GCP from a networking
perspective and offering clients the
ability to run any enterprise workload
that they have directly on this private
cloud from an Oracle perspective it
actually is very Advent Advent Aegis for
the customer with respect to the Oracle
licenses because Oracle as many of you
know if you move your Oracle licenses to
other cloud providers some of the other
ones out there I won't mention the
compete against GCP Oracle will double
the license costs to run it in the cloud
when you run it in this private cloud at
the end of the day it's managed Colo
which customers have been doing for
years and years so their licenses are
completely transferable to run in this
model without getting hit with double
license charges
which makes this very financially
attractive because not only do they get
out of the model of running it in their
own data centers but those licenses they
can still use on this platform so we get
back to over to the results side of this
managed purpose-built
very fast performance for these
applications in many cases for the
clients who are running on old hardware
stacks they're moving to this which is
the latest greatest technology from our
partners in this platform from HPE a
restore networking nimble storage we use
VMware as our base in this
infrastructure including a huge amount
of management and security that
Accenture has built over the years for
Accenture shoes for our own private
cloud and private clouds that we run all
around the world for clients are built
into this platform some very secure and
it also moves into a model for the
customers that's much more flexible
right so they're paying for use of this
infrastructure on a monthly basis it
will show up in their GCP bill as a
monthly charge for use of these services
support will come from Google level one
support and Accenture will be level two
and level three for this offering in the
marketplace so you can see as we're
trying to make this a more integrated
experience for Google clients to quickly
leverage and be able to get access to
this infrastructure for their enterprise
applications like Oracle s ap VMware or
anything else
because it's very very flexible so with
that let me turn it over to frost who's
gonna kind of dive down into the
architecture how this works and then
show you a demo live of the of the
infrastructure of us on GCP
communicating with an Oracle database on
the platform thanks Dan
hi everybody some for osteitis I'm part
of Accenture as Google business group
the AG BG and I manage an offering
that's all around getting your data into
GCP this is one part of that offering
right so as Dan said this is about
getting those workloads that have nado
that you want to get into GCP to do
analytics or a rml against but you have
some block order running it in GCP be
that regulatory be it
formants beat a commercial issue we're
offering our a OPC in those same data
data centers as GCP so that you can get
that data there as Dan said we're
connected within one millisecond we
manage all the networking there's no
data egress costs between the region
that we deploy this and GCP and a OPC so
obviously if you were to take it from
one region to another you pay the
typical networking cost of GCP but right
now for example in US east for where
we're deployed you can run as many
workloads in u.s. used for connect it to
anything running in here and there's no
data egress costs at all so a little bit
about the a OPC at a functional level
what we have here are it's comprised of
kind of three distinct areas the middle
area is the management racks
everything has redundancy in there so
there's two management racks that have
all the software that manages the
environment so that's your provisioning
software your monitoring software your
network security software everything in
there runs in the in those management
racks on the right side we have the
virtual site so this is just a large
VMware farm you could potentially run
anthos we all heard about that this week
you could run anthos on there you can
run individual VMware machines for
example if you've got an older
application that's very chatty with a
database the Oracle database and even
one millisecond for degrades the
performance you can then run those in a
cluster or in a individual VMware guests
on the via on that virtual side on the
left side is the physical bare metal so
that's where we deploy the high
performance compute infrastructure to
support things like 20 terabyte si P
Hana databases or your Oracle databases
you can run and we'll get into the
Oracle kind of standard landscapes in a
little bit the reason that we're putting
Oracle on this side is Dan alluded to is
the Oracle licensing restrictions right
if you take a database and you run it in
a VMware farm you're gonna have to
license all the physical cores whether
or not those are available to your sir
your guests when we because so we're
taking Oracle and deploying it on bare
metal so that you pay the you pay you
have a license cost that's commensurate
to the cores that you have so you have a
couple options
they're right you you'll get some if you
need you know 50 Coors or 40 cores or
whatever you get a physical box and then
there'll be some smaller ones that use
ovm to virtualize so you can get two or
four cores we also have the ability to
configure all our databases within
Oracle Grid and Oracle RAC
configurations so you can have two nodes
three nodes four nodes again that's
therefore H a as well as performance so
that's a little bit of the functional
overview can we go next night please we
alluded this earlier so around the
licensing this is list price right so
just keep that in mind
but we wanted to make sure that we
showed a comparison right if you've got
an Oracle database that's running on
Prem and you're considering moving it to
the cloud if you were to move to one of
the other public cloud providers that
12-core license that you have on Prem
would double in price because ours is
bare metal and or we're using Oracle
technology for virtualization it's the
same EULA cost that does not change you
our model is a BYO l so you do maintain
that list ship with Oracle for support
and by the license but you're able to
transfer that license over to this
environment and license your database
we'll have time for questions later if
anybody's got questions can we move on
so then as far as how we deployed in US
East for right now as I said earlier
we've got two management racks for
redundancy to ensure that we have
availability we use all HPE Hardware in
our environment so we've got nimble
storage everything comes with
solid-state storage both on the physical
side as well as the virtual side
obviously there's virtualization for
that storage but it's still underlying
hardware is HPE nimble and then we've
got the HPE Hartung switches and network
here at the top of rack that we all
manage to segregate network between the
different for clothes that are running
on the environment we go so then we've
worked with Google would have come up
with a couple of different use cases one
use case is an s AP landscape other one
is Oracle and the other one is
individual via more guests because this
is our own hardware and it's a physical
bare metal we're able to host any
workload that can run on
x86 chipset because we're underlying HP
hardware but we we have defined and I'll
and will be available in marketplace by
next week specific use cases just as
guidance for customers that are
interested in this solution so the first
one we'll talk about a little bit is s
ap environments so what we're showing
here is kind of for landscapes that
cover production tests QA and dr for s
AP landscapes that we can deploy
obviously the small and the medium are
things that you can run in GCP right now
right where your certified up to four
terabyte hana I think six terabytes is
coming this summer and eight in the fall
what's interesting is when you get to
the large and the extra-large where we
can scale up to 20 terabyte Hana
databases and scale out to 64 terabytes
using HPE Superdome so this enables the
largest enterprises to run the biggest
sa P environment on bare metal connected
to GC p in certain instances you can
even run part of your SP landscape in GC
p connecting to that HANA or maybe
underlying Oracle database that pet that
manages the data and si P depending on
those applications and and how they
perform we see customers doing that so
that's an interesting option and again
the idea is we're getting your data into
GC p so that you can leverage all the
great things are on data analytics at GC
p enables so around our oracle our first
set of oracle offerings are on physical
environments so it goes from 12 core 24
core and 56 core again as I said earlier
all of these are available in grid
configurations as well as rack
configurations they all come with
they're all backed up I'll talk about a
little bit later when we're doing the
provisioning script what happens is as
you or when you order this you tell us
how many nodes you need you'll give us
some information and then we prove it
will automatically provision them and
give you access to them and we'll show
that in the demo these are the three
t-shirt sizes for Oracle that were
offering through standard through
marketplace and then we also have
smaller virtual Oracle servers starting
at two cores and go up to 16 cores this
uses ovm again right so that you can
you can honor that yield a license for
the core cost and yet it comes the
operating system for all of the Oracle
environments are either Red Hat
Enterprise Linux or Oracle Enterprise
Linux those are the two options for
operating systems there again because
it's it's keep saying again excuse me
because it's bare metal you do have an
option if you have an older version of
Oracle that's maybe not supported we
talked to a customer that had Oracle
version 9 or you want a different
operating system we are able to give you
a bare metal box and then you will
configure that box to meet your needs at
that point some of our support standard
services are run backup and monitoring
no longer in effect because it's a
non-standard deployment but it still
enables you to get some of those older
environments and workloads running into
GCP and connect there you still get all
the network benefits you still get all
the connectivity it's just that some of
our management services will scale back
a little bit because of diversion
control and then finally via you know
individual VMware guests again this is
really meant for if you've got an app or
a web tier that connected to that
database and it's just an older
configuration so that one millisecond
doesn't you still have performance
degradation or you know you're not ready
to hop on a GCE and you've got a couple
of VMware loads you want to run we can
host those here so now we're gonna go
through our demonstration so I'll just
talk you through it
while Matt lines it up so the first
thing is how you order and marketplace
so if you go to marketplace its a tab if
you go to marketplace you'll you'll
search for Accenture and you'll see the
three tiles that we have on there and
one of them is Oracle ones SFP and ones
VMware guests so then you nope okay
sorry there you go yep so when you
select that you'll see that it's
informational where you click learn more
that's our initial integration in the
marketplace due to some limitations
about the ability to add more
subscription so let's say you bought one
Oracle server and you came back three
months later you needed another one we
managed to order through
through a site that Accenture sets up so
as we progress our integration you'll
start to see this actually in Google
console it'll be in a left-hand menu
eventually but right now this is the
process for ordering so if you click on
Oracle and then you click on learn more
which is that link right down there
you'll it'll take you to a screen this
screen you'll enter your start to enter
your customer information so this is the
contact information we need so that we
reach out to you to know who to give
send IP address to and things like that
once you enter that information you'll
click proceed to design and this is
where we capture the technical
information so there's a that didn't
work did it
now contact phone you got a put phone
number so one of the things that will
capture from you is network information
so the way this works is we've got a GCP
project at Accenture administers that
set up in GCP and we've got one week to
create VPC networks for each of the
customers running in this environment
what we do is we need to capture a
network information from yourself so
that we can peer our VPC networks that
enables us to segregate all network
traffic to ensure that your workloads
don't ever conflict with anybody elses
workloads we also want to capture and
then in turn in the network information
your IP range that you want us to
allocate to these servers to your to
your bare metal physical servers right
we're not going to guess what the IP is
we don't want to conflict with an
existing IP range that you have so in
that information do you want to click on
enter network info that button at the
top
you'll see you'll get um let's come up
here second you'll see where you'll
enter the IP range your V PC information
things like that you can hit back or do
that once once you've submitted your
order somebody from Accenture will reach
out to you and confirm that information
and then actually start the VP CPA as
you know you got to do a VP sepia from
both projects so that right will connect
to your VP see you'll connect to yours
will ensure that that peering worked and
all the routes have transferred and then
and we confirm that that works and on
the other screen know if you could can
you hit back on the watering screen
Thanks just down at the bottom hit back
Thanks
so this is where you're in this instance
we're gathering information on the
Oracle environment so you'll tell us you
know what the server size that you want
through the through what's available the
the number of nodes do you need them in
a cluster or not all that information
right how much storage do you want
etcetera so we gather all that
information and then you you know if you
were to hit next which we won't show and
you hit submit order then that's
completed it comes to Accenture and as I
said somebody reaches out to the contact
information this is manual right now
only because of the VP see peering that
needs to happen once that's done all of
the provisioning is automated which
we're going to show next when we when we
get all your information that's that
QuickTime video right we start to
provision the Oracle database and that's
all run through what we call DDI which
is data driven infrastructure this is an
Accenture two separate window you wanna
run the DDI video no it does not
it's QuickTime
so Accenture as Dan said we've had this
private cloud out in the marketplace for
a long time and over the time we've
developed our own orchestration
provisioning we leverage of course
Jenkins and vro from VMware and all
these things but what we've created is a
patented toolset that allows us to
develop what we call application
fingerprints for complex applications so
if you saw earlier I've talked about s
ap landscape right we showed those
landscapes so we could we can actually
automate the build-out of it of a full
end-to-end s AP test landscape that
includes all of your witness servers
your database servers the application
servers everything so that with the data
load so that it's ready to go all in one
fell swoop
so what we're showing here are all the
different Jenkins scripts and all the
things that interact into building out
on our on the bare metal the Oracle
server that we're gonna connect to in
the in the next slide this is all based
on our like I said our thing what's
called DDI
it includes all your operational
software so all the data bases
everything that we deploy standard
backups is incremental nightly and every
week it's a full backup and then we
retain that for 30 days part of the
ordering process is you'll let us know
if that meets your needs or you need
longer retention less retention maybe
you don't want us to back it up at all
you're gonna do it all yourself all of
that stuff so all of those things feed
into these scripts and then we provision
it the way that you've ordered it
just miss here which one dismiss no no
close that just pop up sorry hey I
should be here right now by the way I
think that's what that says ok you want
it you want to switch to the the console
so I don't think you guys are really
interested in watching a bunch of
Jenkins scripts although I can keep that
running it's about an hour and a half
long alright so on the console as I said
earlier right the first thing we need to
do is connect our networks right to do
the V PC pairing so this this project is
meant to mimic your own project on GCP
right this is not the internal Accenture
project that manages the a OPC so within
your project you're gonna create a V PC
network with a subnet right you'll have
communicated that to us in the order
form and we go through the V PC peering
on the left side and connect and connect
our V PC peer that we've developed our
vb c network that we've developed for
you for your environment to your V PC
and that allows us as I said to
segregate all network traffic and have
the routes flow alright so then once
that's done what you're able to do is if
you go into the compute and GCE when you
create a new server a VM on GCP you're
gonna select the network that you build
that on go to the compute keep your
attention there you go
so I've already built out a Windows
server just so that we have a GUI to
show you but when I as I said earlier
when you build that right you're going
to select the network it gets assigned
an IP range within the range that you've
given us all right and then there's
obviously the public IP - to access that
so if we go to the RDP now for that
Windows server it's already downloaded
just go yep click twice twice
come on
password should still be there
so this is a Windows machine in GCP you
just saw that earlier in the console and
if you go to toad we're using toad here
just to show we're gonna connect to the
database the IP of the database is 10
200 0.12 just gonna enter the password
let's hope we got that right so now
we're in the database we're gonna just
upload a quick excel file into that
database under import
scheme under import and third one down
to import table data and then just yeah
go done select under tables in the
drop-down no no the next two one below
it sorry the first one and then you just
have to move it up yeah so I'm gonna
select this in Excel file that's just a
simple CSV and we're gonna trim that
last column it is now uploaded this is
all the data that's in there and if we
go to database or sessions with schema
browser thank you so you can see there
that there is the data that we uploaded
so this is a functioning Oracle database
that's running on the a OPC connected
into GCP and when we we said it's a fast
connection if we switch to the ping so
we're pinging that same IP address 10200
0.22 and you can see that I should look
at the screen it is one millisecond away
so this is still going through the rack
network so it goes up to the top of rack
goes through a firewall that we have
through the segregated VPC back into GCP
hitting a VM within should be less than
one millisecond I think ping doesn't
really show that but at most it's one
millisecond so that should enable you to
run most of your application tier or
your web tier in GCP and still get good
performance back to hit that database as
I said earlier there's no data egress so
you can suck all that data into bigquery
BigTable run MLA I against it any that
any of the cool data stuff that Google
has without data egress cost without
managing an Oracle database getting it
out of your data center
and into GCP you wanna write so I think
yeah back to slides please
so that's our demo the next slide okay
so if you've got any questions obviously
you can ask here we'll be around you can
email a gbg - mps at accenture calm
that'll come to Dan matter myself where
we can help you out with any questions
you can also go to the google cloud
marketplace
that'll be live next week and initiate
you know start an order form that also
get you connected with us I think this
will be shown on that that contact
information will be shown on that first
page a little bit of one more thing
about the ordering I forgot to mention
earlier after you submit the order when
you're ready to proceed what will happen
is we'll send you what's called private
URL pricing again that just has to do
with our ability to be able to add nodes
in the future should you want to do that
things like that so we send you a URL
right to the you know somebody from the
company they click on that and that's
how you execute the order so again it's
Dan who spoke earlier
my name is Feroz and that's Matt
[Music]